William any word to your fans Felicity
Huffman spotted out for the first time
since the release from prison the 56
year old actress and husband William H
Macy were pictured outside a Superior
Court house in Los Angeles on Monday
husband looking casual in flats and a
black suit just days ago prior to her
release from the Federal Correctional
Institution in Dublin California
Felicity was pictured wearing a green
prison jumpsuit Huffman served eleven
days of her 14-day sentence for her role
in the college admissions scandal the
actress admitted to paying $15,000 to
help her daughter get into an elite
college by cheating on her SATs in
addition to her prison time Huffman was
also sentenced to one year of supervised
release a 30 thousand dollar fine and
250 hours of community service so what's
next for the actress a source tells et
quote Felicity knows she has a lot of
work ahead of her to heal her family and
win back the trust of the public her
colleagues and friends she hopes the
public will give her a second chance
[Music]